JONAH JONES: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Today, Yatin and I are going to
give you guys a little talk
about the process we went
through when we were
redesigning the new Google Maps,
as I'm sure you saw in
the keynote on Wednesday.
Hope you guys are
enjoying this.
So, my name's Jonah.
I'm lead designer on the
new Google Maps.
YATIN CHAWATHE: And I'm Yatin.
I'm the engineering director.
I led the team that built
the new Google Maps.
JONAH JONES: So, as we were
going through this process of
doing this redesign from
the ground up--
as Bernie and I mentioned when
we were on the stage on
Wednesday--
there were three main concepts,
and we're going to
do a deep dive on two
of them today.
Now, one of them was that we can
build a new map with every
click, and there are some quite
interesting, difficult
problems that we had to solve
in order to do that.
And another one is that we
wanted to make sure that all
of the imagery we have in the
world is very easy to discover
and fun and immersive as well.
So we're going to go
through those two.
So, on the first one, let's talk
about how we build a map
for every place.
Now, one of the most important
things in building this map
for every place is highlighting
and making sure
that we're labeling
the right roads.
And this is actually
quite a challenging
thing to get right.
So I'll tell you a little
story first.
Which is that--
I like to travel a lot.
And I think it's amazing that
we've got these digital maps
nowadays, and we can carry these
around in our pocket.
And we can look at them on our
computers and everything.
But there's something missing a
little bit from the old days
of having an analog map.
So, this is an example of a map
that was drawn for me when
I first moved to Sydney
a few years ago.
And you probably remember when
you were traveling when you
were a little bit younger,
maybe you went
and stayed in a hotel.
And the hotel concierge
would draw you a map.
And he'd annotate on top
of the existing map.
So, maybe they'd highlight some
of the roads that you
need to use to get to places
that you're interested in.
They'd highlight
places for you.
And this map is great, because
it was a map that has been
drawn for you and is
unique to you.
And it also is quite nice that
it serves as a form of
nostalgia afterwards.
So after your trip is done, you
can take this out one year
later and look back on it.
And we were wondering how we
can build a map that feels
customized to you, but
also fit for purpose.
So, if we look at how Google
Maps looks today, you can see
that this is a fairly
reasonable,
plain map of this area.
This is actually close to
my house in London.
And if we wanted to draw a map
of how to get to this park in
the middle here-- the
Pullens Gardens--
you could imagine that most
traditional maps would
probably just stick a pin
inside the map and
be done with it.
But that probably isn't the
best map that we could
possibly draw for this place.
For a start, the two cross
streets that you see right
next to the Pullens Gardens--
they're not even labeled.
And that's perfectly
reasonable.
These are very small streets,
and in the general scheme of
things, these are not the most
important roads to label here.
But in the context of the
Pullens Gardens, these are
super important.
And you can also see that
generally, there's just a lot
of information.
So even if we were labelling
those streets, no attention
would be drawn to those streets
as being particularly
important amongst all
of the other streets
that we've got nearby.
Now if we were to take
a different approach.
My wife actually just drew
this map on a napkin.
And you can see here that this
is a vastly simplified
representation of how to get to
the Pullens Gardens in the
middle here.
Now this might be a little bit
hard for you to read her
handwriting, so let
me simplify this a
little bit for you here.
This is my diagrammatic
representation of the
information that we're
showing on the
Pullens Gardens map here.
Now we've got several things
we've left out and several
things we've left in here.
So, the first is the
major highways--
the major thoroughfares of the
city I left in, because these
roads are going to always
be important.
Because they're context and part
of the overall structure
of the city.
But the other thing we did was
we drew Penton Place, Amelia
Street, Crampton Street,
Illife Yard--
all of these more minor streets
that you need to take
to get to the Pullens Gardens
from the major streets--
we made sure that those
were highlighted
and labeled as well.
And of course, we also drew--
there's only one point of
interest that's really
important for this one, which
is Kennington station.
This is the local subway
station that
you'd need to get there.
But you could imagine that if
there's other major landmarks
nearby, perhaps where you're
going to be turning off the
streets, they would
be an important
thing to show as well.
So again, here's the map
that we had before.
And now here's the map that we
draw in the new Google Maps.
Now, this isn't quite such a
startlingly different change
as you might first think.
Because you might think, Oh, why
didn't they just draw the
equivalent of this napkin map?
But actually, that's not exactly
what we want in a new,
modern, interactive map, because
maybe you missed your
turning, and you still need to
be able to know what the other
roads are nearby for context.
Or maybe you're going to
drag the map away, or
zoom in, or zoom out.
So we still need a map that's
going to be useful in the
general case, but we're going
to subtly highlight all of
these roads that are important
and make sure
they're labeled as well.
So I'm going to hand you over to
Yatin to explain how we did
this process of selecting
the right roads.
Because although it might be
quite easy for one person to
draw a local road for their
local area, you can imagine
that it's quite challenging to
do this for absolutely any
place in the world.
So I'll hand you over.
YATIN CHAWATHE: Thank
you, Jonah.
So, how do we go
from this map--
which is a very simple base map
with a marker stuck on it
for Pullens Gardens.
This is what you normally see
in the classic Google Maps.
How do you go from here to the
map that Jonah just showed
moments ago?
Well, for starters, Google has
access to a significant amount
of anonymized information
about how our users--
our millions upon millions
of users--
use Google Maps every
single day.
We can analyze all of this
information and use that to
extract signals that allow us
to figure out which roads to
highlight on this map, for
this particular location.
And we can do that over and over
again, every time a user
looks at a map.
So let's look a little
bit more.
What information can we use in
order to figure out which
roads are important for
Pullens Gardens?
What I've shown here is every
single Driving Directions that
any user in Google has ever made
to the general vicinity
of Pullens Gardens.
So we look across all of our
driving directions that users
do millions of times every
single day, and figure out
which of those driving
directions are leading to the
general vicinity of Pullens
Gardens, and created a map
that looks somewhat like this.
Now obviously, this
is a lot of data.
If I use this to highlight every
single road that this
map is showing in blue, that's
not really going to give me
any more compelling of a map
than what we had before.
So what do we do next?
Well, we can look at each one
of these driving directions
and start aggregating them to
figure out which little bit of
road segment--
how popular it is, and how many
of our users are going to
use it to get to Pullens
Gardens.
So you can, again, analyze all
of those Driving Directions
for every road segment that
leads from one intersection to
the next intersection.
You can figure out how many of
those Driving Directions would
have used that particular
segment
to get Pullens Gardens.
And once you do that, you can
rank all of the roads based on
the popularity that they have
for getting to the location
that you want to highlight.
And that's what this version
of the map is showing.
The deep blue roads are the ones
that were marked as more
important, more relevant for
getting to Pullens Gardens.
The light blue ones are all of
the other roads that we had in
the previous slide.
So you're now starting to
see a little bit of
structure to the map.
I'm just going to take away all
of the light blue so we
can see this a little
bit more clearly.
At this zoom level, this now
starts to look like a
relatively clean and useful
map for Pullens Gardens.
It's starting to look very
similar to those napkin
sketches that Jonah was
showing earlier.
Let's zoom in a little bit more
and see what that looks
like at a closer zoom level.
So here's what that same data
looks like as you zoom in to
be able to see the general
neighborhood
around Pullens Gardens.
And notice that those important
roads are still
highlighted.
The roads that actually lead
directly to Pullens Gardens
are also highlighted.
So Penton Place and Amelia
Street are marked
as important there.
But we're still missing some
other important context around
the immediate vicinity
of Pullens Gardens.
The cross streets that abut
either end of Pullens Gardens,
those are not pulled out yet.
So what the next step that the
algorithm does is it does a
very localized search around
the immediate vicinity of
Pullens Gardens and starts to
look for signals that might be
relevant to highlight on the
map for Pullens Gardens.
And what that ends up pulling
out are these two smaller
roads that are not really that
relevant for our Driving
Directions or walking directions
from further away
coming down here, but they are
really relevant as contextual
information.
When I talk about Pullens
Gardens, I'm
going to say, oh, yeah.
It's on Amelia Street
between Illife Yard
and Crampton Street.
And that's what this ends up
allowing us to pull out.
So you put all of this together
and you have the set
of roads that you might
want to highlight.
So now you have the base signals
that you want to use
to create the map that
Jonah showed earlier.
Again, as he mentioned, you
don't really want to just show
a map as desaturated as this.
You end up losing a lot of other
contextual information
that may be useful to some
users, even though it's not
the most useful information
for this place.
So how do you go about
doing that?
Let's start again with the base
map and just a marker.
That's all we have.
And now let's start pulling in
the signals that we captured
in the previous slide.
So the first step that the
algorithm does is it runs a
restyling filter on
this basemap.
For every single road that we
picked out as an important
road that we marked as blue in
that previous slide, we will
increase the intensity of the
color and the strokes
used for that road.
So I'm going to flip back and
forth between these a couple
of times so you can see
it more clearly.
Here is what the basemap
looks like.
Here's what the new
map looks like.
Basemap.
And new map.
And what you see is that the
roads that are important have
now become wider, and
the strokes have
become darker and stronger.
So they get pulled out a little
bit, but not so much as
to be in your face.
And the other thing you notice
is all the other roads get
dimmed out a little bit.
Those other roads are
not as relevant.
You don't want to take them off
the map, because somebody
else might care about them.
You want to leave them on the
map, but reduce their
intensity so that you can
actually pull out the roads
that matter.
So again, just one last time,
I'm going to show the previous
thing, and the new one.
So this is step one.
You restyle everything.
But notice that the streets that
we thought were really
relevant, like Crampton Street
and Amelia Street, are still
not labeled on the map.
So that's the next step that the
algorithm does is it runs
a relabeling pass in real time,
as you've just clicked
on this location, and
that gives you this.
So now, Amelia Street is
labeled, Crampton Street is
labeled, and we've made the
label for Pullens Gardens a
little bit bolder and stronger
because that is obviously the
most important label here.
Again, I'll flip back and
forth once or twice.
Here's what it looked like, and
here's what the new thing
looks like.
The other thing that the map
does is it takes away some of
the labels on the less
relevant streets.
So minor side streets that
might have been labeled
earlier because there was enough
space on the map to
label them, we'll take away
some of those labels.
Because those labels don't
matter nearly as much anymore.
But the labels of the streets
that are nearby that we've
identified as important
streets-- they're really
important, so we'll label
them more strongly.
So this, in a nutshell, is the
core set of algorithms that we
use to figure out how to create
a map that is truly
about Pullens Gardens.
And we take advantage of the
immense amount of computing
power that we have at our
disposal in Google's data
centers to be able to run this
algorithm every single second,
for every single user,
for every single
task that they perform.
The next thing we're going
to talk about--
I'm going to hand it back to
Jonah-- is to talk a little
bit more about how we explore
the world around us, around
Pullens Gardens or one of the
other places that you might
want to search on the map.
JONAH JONES: All right,
thanks Yatin.
So when I first joined Google,
I was living in London, and
then I went and joined
the Zurich office.
And so, I packed up my bags and
went and traveled there.
And I was living in
Zurich, and that
was all very exciting.
And every Christmas, I would
come back, and I
would visit my family.
And my grandma, at the time, she
was getting quite old, and
she wasn't really able
to travel anymore.
But she really wanted to
know what it was like
nearby where I lived.
And she'd never been to
Switzerland either.
So this is a picture
of Street View--
and this is my house
in Zurich--
and the amazing thing was from
our living room or our kitchen
in London, I was able to
go use Google Maps.
And we were able to fly to
street level and go and
explore the area around
where I lived.
And we called this going
for a drive.
And this was incredible,
because it gave her the
ability to travel to Switzerland
and actually see
this area where I lived.
Now, my grandma's no longer with
us, unfortunately, but if
I had the ability to fast
forward and show her what
we've done today, I think I'd
be really proud to show her
what we've done.
Because not only do we have this
immersive Street View, we
also have this incredible Earth
inside the browser,
which lets you feel as if you're
flying all over the
city in a helicopter.
And we also have these amazingly
immersive 3D tours.
And this is actually a photo
that I took of the
main river in Zurich.
And the 3D tools are a really,
really interesting part of
this, which have very difficult
engineering
challenges associated
with them.
And we wanted to make sure that
this wasn't a horrible,
overwhelming, enormous
slide show.
And we want to make sure that it
was also more immersive and
more engaging than just flipping
through one photo
after the other.
So we used a lot of techniques
from cinematography to make
sure that we picked the right
photos and transition nicely
between them.
And, again, as with that napkin
map, this might be a
fairly easy task for a human
to do if they were to do it
one by one by one.
But if you're going to generate,
using an algorithm,
a great 3D tool for thousands
and thousands of places for
all over the world, this is
a pretty challenging task.
So I'm going to hand it back
to Yatin to explain how we
went about doing this.
YATIN CHAWATHE: Thanks, Jonah.
So, before I delve into the
technical details--
before I go into the technical
details of how we build these
3D tours, let's take a
look at a 3D tour in
the new Google Maps.
What this is is a tour of the
Notre Dame Cathedral in Paris,
which is one of my favorite
cities in the world.
And it's showing you
many different
facades of the cathedral.
It shows you a lot of detail
work on some of the most
interesting aspects of the
cathedral, and then zooms out
and rotates around to
give you a final
other view of the cathedral.
So how did we go about building
this 3D tour and
other 3D tours like it?
Again, one of the big themes
around how we went about
building a lot of the
technologies behind the new
Google Maps is the immense
amount of information that
Google has access to.
So for 3D photo tours, the core
set of information that
we started to look at is the
thousands upon thousands of
photos that users like you and
I and Jonah have uploaded to
Google for public consumption
by everyone else.
So this might include photos
that you might have uploaded
to Google+ that you've
explicitly marked as shareable
with the entire world, photos
that users might have uploaded
to the Panoramio photo sharing
site, and any other similar
site within the Google
ecosystem.
So what this is showing you is
just a sliver of the tens of
thousands of photos
that we have of
the Notre Dame cathedral.
There's a whole bunch of these
photos, and what we want to
now do is figure out, how do you
take all of these photos
and go from them, and create a
single photo tour out of them.
So the first step of the
entire process involves
running a long series of
complex computer vision
algorithms that analyze this
entire collection of photos
for the Notre Dame, and try to
figure out exactly where that
photo was taken in the real
world, and where in the real
world every single pixel in
every one of these photos
corresponds to.
So for each pixel in every
photo, we know exactly which
other pixel in every other
photo that particular one
might correspond to.
And what that allows us to build
is a fairly detailed
three-dimensional model of
the Notre Dame cathedral.
And I'll show you what such
a model would look like.
So what you're seeing here is
what we call a 3D point cloud.
It's a whole bunch of dots
thrown into three-dimensional
space-- and then I've
just captured a
screen shot of that--
and what each of these dots
represents is one point across
the entire set of photos
that we identified.
Each of these points identifies
a point that was
matched in a set of pixels
across all of these photos.
And you can see, although the 3D
point cloud isn't complete,
you can clearly see that this
is a representation of the
Notre Dame Cathedral.
So what do we do once we have
this 3D point cloud?
The next step is, again,
as I said earlier--
we have on the order of tens of
thousands of photos of the
Notre Dame.
If I were to show you all of
those, that would look like a
tour of your poor cousin's trip
that he took, and you
don't want to really sit through
those 10,000 photos.
So what we really want to pull
out is a handful of photos
that really represent, that
bring out the essence of what
the Notre Dame looks like.
One thing we want to capture is,
what does the Notre Dame
look like in context?
What does it look like in the
surroundings where it's
physically located?
So that's one photo zoomed out
far enough where you can see
the entire cathedral.
You see it's right on the main
river that runs through Paris.
You want another one that really
brings out what the
cathedral is about.
So this is a front facade
photo of the cathedral.
Each of these photos that we're
picking, we also rank
them based on how popular
they are.
How many users have looked at
that photo, How many people
like that photo, and so on.
Here's the third photo.
This really gives you a
sense of detail that
represents the cathedral.
Again, this is the central arch
in the front facade of
the cathedral.
And what this is capturing is
one of the main aspects of the
cathedral that lots and
lots of users are
taking pictures of.
Another thing you might want
to capture is yet another
perspective on what the
cathedral looks like.
So you might want something that
captures a photo from the
right hand side and then yet
another one that shows you the
right hand side facade of the
cathedral, as we saw at the
end of the tour.
So this gives you somewhat of a
sense of what the cathedral
would look like from
various angles.
But that's not quite enough to
really give you an immersive
sense of what the cathedral
feels like if you
were to visit it.
So another thing we look for is
really picturesque photos
of the cathedral.
And there's a number of signals
that we can take into
account when identifying photos
that are considered
picturesque.
What this shows you is a very
beautiful nighttime view of
the cathedral.
The cathedral is beautifully lit
up and really gives you a
sense of a very different way
of looking at the cathedral.
What might be examples of photos
that you don't want to
choose for your photo tour?
Here's a couple.
Now, this photo on the left--
it's a really beautiful photo
of a bunch of flowers.
If you want to look at the
cathedral, it's not nearly as
representative of
the cathedral.
You can see bits and pieces of
the cathedral in the top left
corner, but they're
kind of blurry and
not really in focus--
it's not a very representative
photo.
And then that other photo
on the right.
It's a wonderful family enjoying
a great vacation in
Paris, not something that's
representative
to this entire audience.
So those are a few things that
we look for when we try to
figure out which photos may
not be good photos as
canonical photos.
So now we have all
of these photos.
What those green dots around the
3D point cloud are showing
is the specific camera position
where that photo was
taken from.
And this is, again, something we
can infer as we're building
the 3D point cloud.
So now we have a set of photos,
and we know where
those photos were taken from.
What's the next step?
What Jonah mentioned earlier
when he was giving you a very
high level overview of these
photo tours is, we want to
take into account how
cinematographers have really
thought about how to navigate
through a scene, create a
camera motion model that really
reflects that and gives
you a very smooth, fluid motion
throughout the entire scene.
So we take all the canonical
photos and arrange them such
that you can create a path from
camera position to camera
position that feels very
fluid and natural.
And that's what this reflects.
We're going from the photo on
the bottom right all the way
around in clockwise direction.
Let's take all of those and
arrange them in sequence now.
So that's what this
would look like.
So if you only took this
information and started to
create a 3D slide show out of
this, you would end up with a
lot of artifacts.
Going from the photo on the far
left to that next photo,
nighttime photo of the
cathedral, you're going to see
a lot of stretching if you try
to just warp one photo into
the next photo.
So what you want to do now is
identify a few interstitial
frames that you can use to
really create a smooth
transition effect.
Now, what you know here is the
set of photos that you really
want to linger the camera on.
And then you just want to
identify a few additional
photos that you can breeze
through without
spending a lot of time.
And you know the general camera
path that your tour is
going to take.
So what you can now do is go
back to your dataset of tens
of thousands of photos and start
looking for a few other
photos that match that
general camera path.
And that gives you something
like this.
Those red dots are the new
camera positions that we added
where we found a few
interstitial frames, and we
added those frames to this
entire sequence.
Now these interstitial frames,
they don't need to be terribly
high quality.
You can use fairly
low-resolution photos and
still be OK because they're
merely being used as filler
material as you're going from
one photo that you're going to
linger the camera on
to the next photo.
So you have a lot of flexibility
in being able to
identify photos that really give
you a very nice, smooth
transition.
You put all of this together,
and that ends up giving you a
3D tour of the Notre Dame.
We can do this not just for the
Notre Dame, but for any
other landmark around the world,
and we can do it not
just for landmarks.
So let's go back to the center
of Zurich where Jonah used to
live and see a photo tour
of the center of Zurich.
This is showing you a tour
around the Limmat River in the
center of Zurich.
And it gives you sort of a nice
360 degree view of the
heart of Zurich.
So this was a very quick
overview, but I hope you were
able to get somewhat of a sense
of what the underlying
techniques are that go into
building these 3D photo tours.
So before I wrap up, I just want
to go back and summarize
the two main things
that we covered.
The first one was, how do you
build a map of a place every
single time, for every
single user?
We use a lot of information
that Google has access to
about how places are structured,
how people
navigate to get to those places,
to build these maps.
And the second is, once you
figure out how to get
somewhere, you want to really
get to know that place better.
And so we have a number of
different techniques that we
use to really give you a rich,
immersive feeling for what
these places look like
in the real world.
Now both of these techniques
that I described, they are
very much in their
infancy today.
We think we've taken a very big
leap forward with the new
Google Maps from what online
mapping can do these days, but
we still have a long
way to go forward.
And we hope that you've
enjoyed what we've
shown you so far.
We believe there are a lot of
still very hard, difficult
computer science problems to
solve that will keep making
these experiences better
and better over time.
And we hope you will continue
on the journey with us as we
try to make a mapping experience
that is truly
unique, truly for you, and truly
about every single task
that you do every single day.
With that, I think we'd like
to open it up for any
questions you might have.
There is a pair of microphones
here that you can walk up to,
and we'll be able to take any
kind of questions and
not drop the mike.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I wondered when do you
think we might see the new
personalized maps showing up on
mobile, on Android AND iOS?
JONAH JONES: So the thing that
we talked about during the
keynote on Wednesday was that
we kind of came up with this
vision of how the future of
Google Maps would be as we're
moving forward.
So the thing that we announced
on desktop on Wednesday was
the desktop incarnation of where
we're heading towards in
that future, and I think that
as time progresses, you're
going to generally see this kind
of experience be mirrored
across all different devices,
because we want everyone to
have a very seamless experience
across all devices.
So the desktop is a preview
of where we are now.
YATIN CHAWATHE: So
what we have now
is the desktop version.
We will continue to work on
improving our look and feel of
Maps and unifying them across
all of our platforms.
AUDIENCE: In terms of how the
new mapping system relates to
the old mapping system, how much
extra does it cost you in
terms of compute power
to do this?
And is there any saving in
terms of data flow from
cutting down these maps?
YATIN CHAWATHE: I can't go into
a lot of specifics on
exactly what is different, but
we take advantage of a lot of
different levels of both
simplification and easier and
better serving systems to allow
us to build these maps.
So, obviously, creating a map
on the fly for every single
user, every single task that
they perform, is going to take
more computing power.
But we try to be fairly
efficient about how we go
about doing it so it doesn't
become an overwhelming thing.
Even for Google, we do want to
be conscious about not using a
lot of compute power, so we try
to be fairly efficient.
JONAH JONES: There's a
distinction between, of
course, client side computing
power and the server side
computing power as well, so in
terms of the download that you
get to your local machine,
the amount of data
we send should be--
for the basic map case-- should
be similar or even less
because it's more efficient
with sending vector maps.
YATIN CHAWATHE: That is true.
Because we send vector data down
to the client, now the
total amount of data
that we send to the
client is much lower.
And we can take advantage of all
of the compute power that
each of you have to draw
the map for us.
So that becomes a shared
responsibility where we do all
the hard work in our
infrastructure and then send
very simple information down
to the client and allow the
client to render stuff.
AUDIENCE: I think one of the
most interesting things was
the way you guys did the WebGL
rendering in the browser.
And reading the media coverage
about this, it doesn't seem
like anybody noticed that.
I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the
challenges of doing that.
I'm specifically interested in
how you're able to share that
code across all the different
platforms you're supporting
including Android and iOS.
YATIN CHAWATHE: So the WebGL
stuff that we worked on is
primarily for desktop.
The vector maps that our mobile
platforms use, use a
native variant of it.
We do try to share a lot of
themes across all of these
platforms, so we have the same
look and feel for the Maps no
matter which platform
you're browsing on.
So when it comes to a bunch of
the 3D rendering, we share a
number of the low level shader
code that each of these
platforms rely on, but then
WebGL, iOS, and Android have
their own variants of
implementation on top of that
that are native to the platforms
that we work on.
AUDIENCE: So what you showed
here is a very cool, but you
said it is still in
an early stage.
What I'm curious to know is,
what are the major areas you
see that needs to be enhanced?
YATIN CHAWATHE: Be enhanced?
Sure.
There's a lot of improvement
we can make to our product
every single time.
We are very proud and very
happy about how far we've
come, but there is so much
more that can be done.
A map that is truly about
you continues to evolve.
As I evolve, as you evolve, what
we expect out of online
maps evolves.
We're going to continue
to want to improve it.
So we see this sort of as just
one step forward in what
people will come to expect
out of online maps.
As people get to used to this
new way of exploring the
world, there will be newer and
newer things that we'll want
to do with our maps.
There's a number of interesting
ideas that
hopefully we'll be able to share
with the world as we
start building those and
creating an even richer
experience.
JONAH JONES: Yeah, I think
it's a really interesting
challenge, because the two
things that we showed today
are kind of trying to
algorithmically generate
something that a talented human
would be able to do, and
that's really tough, right?
So I feel like the fact that
we've got as far as we have
with the 3D tool is amazing,
but that's still--
if it were a human doing it, it
would become a mediocre 3D
tour, right?
And wouldn't it be amazing
if the 3D tour could be
incredible like one of the top
directors has done it.
And very similar with
the hand drawn maps.
I think it's amazing how far
we've come, but there's still
a long way we can
go with that.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a fixed
database of landmarks for
which you generate the 3D tours,
or is it just possible
for anyone to ask for a
3D tour of any place,
essentially, on the planet?
YATIN CHAWATHE: We--
it varies.
So, we can create the 3D tour of
any place for which we have
a large number of photos.
You do require a reasonable
number of photos.
If you only have five to 10
photos, you can't really
extract a rich enough 3D
structure out of that.
But once you have enough photos
of a place, then it's
pretty easy to create
a 3D tour of that.
Now, obviously, we don't have
anything in our current
product that allows you to
just create a 3D tour of
something that you
generate, but--
so what we take into account
are signals like, what are
places that are going to be
interesting to our users, what
are the most relevant places
for, say, any given city
around the world, and try to
take those signals into
account when we figure
out where we want to
publish these 3D tours.
But the basic concept--
if you took 1,000 photos of your
house, you would be able
to create a 3D tour
of your house.
JONAH JONES: If everyone in
this room went outside and
took a photo of the Moscone
Center, we'd probably have a
Moscone Center tour
pretty soon.
AUDIENCE: So do you choose these
places manually, or is
there some algorithm that
chooses those places?
YATIN CHAWATHE: No , we don't
choose them manually, it's
algorithmic, there's
many, many tours
around the whole world.
So, yeah, there's a whole bunch
of algorithms and a
number of signals
that go into it.
Basically, at a very high
level, it's driven by
popularity.
The most popular places we
want to create tours for.
AUDIENCE: Somewhat related to
the previous question, when
you're looking at all these
thousands of photos, is there
some level of manual filtering
that you do with the photos,
as well, or is it purely
algorithmic?
YATIN CHAWATHE: The first pass
is purely algorithmic.
We do perform some manual
moderation to verify that the
algorithms work well.
That will go down over time as
we gain more confidence and as
we gain more signals to feed
into our algorithms.
JONAH JONES: I think there's
quite a lot of manual work
that goes even before this as
well, right, because the
photos that are selected are the
popular ones for Panoramio
or from Picasa.
And something being popular is
obviously a very, very human
thing which is, people like it,
they share it, all of that
kind of thing.
So there is very much a human
element in the beginning
[INAUDIBLE]
about the popularity, and
then the algorithm
takes over from there.
YATIN CHAWATHE: And that
manual work is taking
advantage of the immense
human computing power
of the entire world.
AUDIENCE: Just to touch back on
the idea that if I was to
take 1,000 photos of my house,
a 3D tour could be
created around it.
Is that a service that you
might want to offer to
amateurs like me, that I could
plug a bunch of photos in and
it would do that for me?
YATIN CHAWATHE: It sounds like
a great idea, we'll have to
take it into account.
Any more questions?
I don't think there's anything
else here, but--
JONAH JONES: We're lucky that
didn't happen in the keynote.
[LAUGHTER]
YATIN CHAWATHE: All right, this
thing has the old password.
JONAH JONES: All right.
It looks like that's all the
questions then, so, thank you
everyone for coming.
[APPLAUSE]